Here's another way of thinking about this trade-off.
We want to balance the errors that our regression gives us,
with the number of features that are required to get those errors.
We're going to try to maximize the quality of the model that we're making.
I haven't totally defined this yet, but let me fill out this graph, and
you'll get a sense for what I mean by this.
Let's suppose I have only one feature in my model.
Then, I would say that the likelihood is pretty high that I'm
under-fitting my data
that I have something that's very high-bias.
So, I'd say the quality of the model might be all right.
But, not as good as it could be.
Now, let's suppose that I allow a little bit more complexity into my model.
I allow to use three features.
And, I happen to pick three features that are good at
describing the patterns in the data.
Then, my error is going to go down,
because it's my model is now fitting my data in a, in a more precise way.
But it's not too complex yet.
I'm only using three features, and I've checked each one of them.
So, the quality of my model has now gone up.
So, then I say, well, that's pretty sweet.
I can improve my model, just by adding more features into it.
So, let me try to add in a whole bunch of features.
I'm going to jump up to 15.
And, I'm hoping that that'll put the quality of my model,
say somewhere up here, at the maximal value that it can have.
What I'll actually find though, is that I'm starting to become susceptible to
this over-fitting, high variance type regime.
So, maybe the quality of my model has actually become a little bit
lower than the quality that it was at, at three features.
Because, now I'm starting to over fit,
where before I was under-fitting with one, I'm now over fitting with 15.
And, if I were to go all the way out to 20,
then I might even be doing worse than if I had only one input feature.
And, so you could imagine that if I sort of filled out this,
this graph for all of the possible number of features that I could get, there
would be some best point where the quality of my model is going to be maximized.
So, a reasonable thing to think, and what we'll talk about for the next few
videos, is how we can mathematically define what this arc might be so
that we can find this maximum point of it.
And, this is a process that's called regularization.
It's an automatic form of feature selection that some algorithms can
do completely on their own, that they can trade off between the precision,
the goodness of fit, the very low errors, and, the complexity of,
of fitting on lots and lots of different features.
So, let me show you an example of how regularization works in regressions.